wonderful um thank you everyone uh
thanks to the organizers for the
opportunity uh to be presenting here
um I'm quite excited to to talk about uh
an experiment that we did at IBM uh
that's the culmination of about six or
seven years of work into error
mitigation that went hand in glove with
our Hardware development
um and uh I think before I start out I
want to really acknowledge the people
who made this work possible uh youngster
came and Andrew weddings uh uh who who
led the experimental work
um and uh you know there's been several
years of work into better mitigation
that's been you know done in
collaboration with Kristen teme Sergey
and Jay gambetta
um and and this work also has a very big
Berkeley uh stamp we collaborated
actively with with Mike xylitol's group
um uh and and a lot of the the numerical
work was was led by sajanth Anand right
and as I said this this is work that
went quite hand in hand with the
hardware development so this it'll be
fairly obvious that this this couldn't
have been possible with the
contributions of the entire IBM team
okay so uh this is this is a paper
that's going to be coming out tomorrow
uh titled evidence for the utility of
quantum Computing before fall tolerance
uh and uh you know internally it's the
title we've haggled about uh quite a bit
um and and hopefully I can I can
convince you that you know we weren't
completely crazy okay
um so so maybe it's important to for
state the very obvious thing we're not
we're not claiming that advanced
algorithms can be done without fault
tolerance things like Shores and uh that
that very much is something you know
we'll still need to to uh to try a name
for and that that remains a very big
goal of what we're trying to do with an
IBM
but if we look at the the vast majority
of near-term quantum algorithms that
have been run on Hardware
um the core primitive of these relies on
running a short depth Quantum circuit
within your coherence budget and the
estimation of some expectation value
okay and what we're showing in this
experiment is today with a quantum
computer at a scale Beyond 100 qubits to
the scale Beyond Brute Force classical
computation we can report accurate
expectation values
all right
and so yeah I think to this audience I
don't need to motivate why it's very
hard to build a quantum computer you
know compared to the errors that we have
uh in in the building blocks of
classical computers and and long term
you know we we all want some kind of
error correction to really access what
what we can do with Quantum Computing
right
um and and all of this the the long-term
solution has has been to to to to to
encode information in a in a larger
lattice to recall to decode to
delocalize Quantum information
um and and this is this has been one
motivation for building larger and
larger lattices of humans okay we do
want to test
um what what some error correction codes
might look like but but even at this
size the latest being 433 we aren't
anywhere close to to doing something
practical with you know towards fault
tolerance
um uh you know we had a uh an earlier uh
revision of our of our Hardware of our
Hardware family with the Hummingbird
Processor with 65 qubits you know
perhaps one could argue that already at
this scale you're you're beyond
um you know what one could do with with
Brute Force classical computation so so
if you didn't have fault tolerance yet
what can one actually try to do with
these systems okay so maybe we can we
can do a very quick back of the envelope
calculation
um assuming we had 100 qubits one of
these devices and we wanted to run a
circuit with about 10 000 Gates and you
know with superconducting Quantum
technology you know we have we have two
qubit gate fidelities the best ones at
99.9 level so if you wanted to estimate
a state fidelity
that's going to be 5e minus four okay
this is incredibly lousy uh is there
anything useful we can do with when the
fidelities of that group right
um and then one can ask well instead of
trying to preserve that Quantum state
which is what we're trying to do with
error correction uh can we instead ask
the question is it possible to estimate
properties of what that ideal state was
or would have been okay
um and uh this is a very simplistic
example but I find it quite useful uh to
think of so if you had about a thousand
spins and they were all aligned in the
same direction right
um and and so so the global
magnetization is now one for this for
the spin system if I flipped one of
these
the Fidelity the overlap between the two
states is zero but if I instead asked
what was the global magnetization again
that answer is only wrong to the third
digit right
so what does that tell me perhaps there
are quantities that one could measure
even with noise that that aren't you
know as
as bad as the worst case metric as this
Fidelity there might be certain
quantities Like This Global
magnetization right
um expectation values like this so our
expectation values interesting things to
measure right uh yes I mean you can you
can you can ask you know what what are
the Dynamics of interacting spin systems
very often
um interested in in measuring things
like the magnetization you know more
complex correlation functions
um in machine learning algorithms kernel
estimation
um uh if we're running a variation
algorithm for for for chemistry and are
interested in binding energies that
relies on on expectation value so really
the the measurement of expectation
values for short depth Quantum circuit
is really you know a key component of of
uh what we're doing in the near term
okay
so this was something we uh we went down
the path even in 2017 uh and and this
was an example of a just a four cubic
experiment with a circuit depth of two
where we were trying to to uh simulate
the ground state energies of a very
simple toy model a model representing
um lithium hydride and what you have
here is is the energy is a function of
inter-atomic distance this is a four
qubit problem so you know what the ideal
uh uh binding energies
um would look like and if you ran this
on on the device those are the those are
the results that you get and and if you
ask a Quantum chemist you know this
inaccuracy is just orders of magnitude
beyond anything they care about right
um so this was already you know
indicating that something else needs to
be done
um and and essentially internally with
Christian Sergey and Jay we invented a
set of techniques called error
mitigation there was simultaneous work
from Simon Benjamin's group at Oxford
but essentially a bunch of techniques
saying that even with an existing noisy
quantum computer you can do some post
processing to extract Noise free
expectation values
okay
um
I'm going to primarily talk about one of
the techniques that was introduced in
this work this is um the zero noise
extrapolation so if if you have some
observable that you care about and you
can express it as a Taylor series in
some noise parameter Lambda the goal is
to suppress these higher order noise
terms and then access the zero noise
limit
so as an experimentalist if I had you
know some very explicit control over the
noise and they can precisely amplify
this noise by a factor of c and I
re-measure that expectation value you
know expressing it out to the the second
order this is what I have but with these
two estimations now I can construct a
new estimate where I've suppressed the
leading order noise term to order Lambda
Square okay
in principle with with n estimations I
can reduce the you know the the error to
the the leading order error term to to
order Lambda to the end this is
Richardson extrapolation okay of course
you'll be you'll be limited at some
point by by by the sampling cost
um but but then one relevant question
then is well how do you even measure
these these energies these Amplified
bonds levels this isn't something that's
but that's that's trivial to do right
um so one trick that we came up with was
under the assumption that your noise is
time invariant if you basically
stretched out all your control pulses in
time so say you had 100 nanosecond pulse
you stretch it down time to 200
nanoseconds and rerun the circuit now
that circuit is sensitive to more noise
okay and that gets you access to to an
expectation value with an amplified
noise rate this is making certain
assumptions but this is something we we
tried nonetheless and then with these
Amplified uh noise measurements you can
you can try and extrapolate back to the
zero noise limit
so um this was then um you know with
this technique this was this was worth
revisiting that lithium hydride
experiment uh two years later and then
you can basically see here that we were
we were re-measuring these these
energies at four different noise levels
and trying to extrapolate to what that
energy would have been in the absence of
noise and and the agreement is much
better okay
um but this is still a four qubit
experiment right
um how does this how does this scale
um so basically if you're trying if you
look at the theoretical bounds in the
original uh PRL your your bounds are
basically the remainder in that Taylor
series and you you want this n Lambda T
to be a small number the number of
qubits your Lambda noise parameter which
you can think of as you know say the
inverse of your coherence time and and
the total circuit Evolution time
so this isn't you know very promising uh
in the sense that this is this is
telling you that if you wanted to to
scale up the volume of your circuit you
also need to scale down the the the
total noise by the same factor right and
and so in in this work which I won't get
into we basically wanted to test out how
um how tight were these bounds in
practice right and it turns out that you
can actually have you know better
performance in an experiment and and
this is essentially the blueprint for
the work I'll be talking about right now
and you know in this we went up to 26
qubits going up to a depth of 120. Okay
so we've had a few um different error
mitigation experiments ongoing this is
kind of the lay of the land so far
um as you heard the previous speaker say
we're trying to get into this this
hundred by hundred territory
um 100 qubits with a depth of hundred
and the experiment I'll be talking about
today will be one where we go up to uh
you know uh 100 we use 127 qubits and go
up to a circuit depth of 60.
so
um what made this experiment possible
one it's of course building a Quantum
system at the scale right it's very
complicated as you can see from uh from
from this picture but but beyond the
devices there's a host of supporting
infrastructure that goes in the fridge
the control Electronics the software to
actually have a reliable 127 qubit
Quantum system we have this with our
Eagle family of devices
the next is is coherence when we when we
built our first Eagle device
um that's what I refer to as R1 this was
the distribution of coherence times
those got better by a factor of two or
three in in the device that we used this
this naturally plays into the kind of
circuit depth we can we can we can
achieve our coherence budget Grows Right
you have 127 qubits how do you calibrate
all the two qubit gates on this right
typically the way to do this is to to
optimize the two qubit gates for every
link but for the kind of circuits I'll
be talking about we were more interested
in optimizing the performance of a gate
layer where we're heavily parallelizing
a number of two qubit gate operations
there were some you know some some novel
Innovations in in how we can how we can
optimize for that and also improve uh
the performance of the the entire gate
layer okay so that was also something we
were able to do
and then the final piece was the ability
to characterize and manipulate noise
accurately right this is crucial because
the the more the the better we can we
can manipulate our noise the more
accurately we can error mitigate the
more accurately we can extrapolate
towards uh the zero noise limit
okay so far so good any
any questions can I keep going ahead
okay
um lovely okay so so so so what was the
innovation in in our noise amplification
scheme I'm going to talk about a
technique that we'll call probabilistic
error amplification and for this let's
consider a very simple example of just a
single qubit experiment where we have
some noisy unitary on some initial State
and we want to measure the expectation
value
okay and the expectation value we
measure here is this is the noisy one at
the base noise rate okay
um
and we can model this basically as some
noise Channel that's that's applied on
on the ideal gate okay
um now
we want to amplify the noise for
Simplicity let's say we want to amplify
The Noise by a factor of two okay so
what this would amount to would be
essentially having an additional noise
Channel
um in this circuit right but how do you
actually implement this in practice
um once again just for the purpose of
this example let me consider a very
simple poly channel one where I where I
can you know when I express as a bit
flip uh with the probability P which
which I've characterized and I have
access to right and if I know that you
can basically see that the expectation
value at this Amplified noise can be
obtained by probabilistically sampling
between these two different circuits
okay uh with p and 1 minus B right and
and although this is an example for one
particular amplification factor for just
a single qubit with a particular noise
this can be generalized you can do this
for for more complicated poly channels
you can do this for arbitrary gain
factors
um they don't even need to be positive
you can go negative and you can have a g
equals minus one where you completely
cancel the noise this is this is you
know uh for the experts in the the
audience this is referred to as
probabilistic error cancellation that
comes at an exponential sampling cost
but but that's also something that could
be done okay
but this is a very simple one qubit
example
um
in general we're looking at circuits
like this the multi qubit circuits many
layers
um once again let's let's perhaps look
at examples of circuits where you can
you can look at single qubit Gates and
then uh layers of two qubit operations
on on all the on all the qubits and once
again this is also something we can
model is the effect of some noise
channel on on the ideal unitary okay
um but then this noise channel is going
to going to have many different noise
contributions uh you're going to have
crosstalk errors the coherence T1 T2
um you know even within crosstalk there
can be many different types of crosstalk
classical crosstalk Quantum crosstalk
some correlated errors control errors
because maybe we haven't calibrated the
device perfectly all of this needs to be
captured in this this noise Channel and
this is an incredibly hard problem right
you need 4 to the N by 4 to the N
parameters to completely characterize
this much right so this needs some
simplification okay so for that we use a
technique that's called poly twirling
where we basically
sample polygates on on uh on every qubit
and then on the other side of that noisy
layer you you basically undo these
polygates to have the same logical
equivalent layer and over many
polyrandomizations you can basically uh
on average tailor this noise into a poly
Channel one where you only have these
diagonal terms okay so this is a very
useful simplification
um but it's still very hard you still
have 4 to the N minus one uh terms to
um from
so the only real hope
to play this game is to is to somehow
reduce this exponential complexity to
something polynomial based on some
reasonable physics assumptions okay and
for that we basically turn to this the
sparse poly limblad model which we
introduced in in this work and
essentially what we're doing here is
that this composite
um uh noise channel can be expressed as
a composition of uh of simpler poly Maps
um and and basically here we're only
including those poly terms whose support
is is you know is weight one on every
qubit and then weight two on every
connected pair of keywords so for the
heavy hex topology that we have in our
processors with with nearest neighbor
connectivity this basically amounts to
uh you know a linear number of of noise
parameters
okay
um
and once again if you look at this it it
basically reduces to the problem we had
in the one in that simple one qubit
example for each of the poly terms
you're flipping a coin and then you can
you can manipulate the Noise by doing
nothing with this probability and and
and you know introducing introducing
some poly error with with that
probability with one minus w
but how do you learn these noise
parameters okay that's the next question
um so if if you had a poly Channel and
you wanted access to these fidelities
this is pretty well known the the way to
do this is to have many repetitions of
this this Channel and then if you if you
measured the the poly expectations that
you got at different depths and and fit
it to the Decay you would get access to
these fidelities okay but in practice
you don't you don't quite have the
ability to separate to separate out the
noise channel from the gate they're tied
to each other so instead what you have
to do is if for instance if you had a
layer of C naught Gates you try and
construct an identity equivalent block
so for instance even repetitions of
these C naughts and then you keep
repeating them
um the action of the the gate layer is
going to mix fidelities so so when you
look at these dks you're going to get
access to pairs of fidelities okay but
because of these these sparsity
assumptions that we made
you have
um you have a limited number of model
parameters we want to learn therefore
you can get away with a limited number
of fidelity estimations this way
um and and basically construct your
model by uh by uh uh
a non-negative least Square optimization
problem
okay
um so with that we're basically able to
to construct an average noise Model A
noise model on average for a 127 qubit
uh gate layer okay and essentially what
we've been able to do here is we've been
able to reduce the number of parameters
we want to learn from something that's
10 to the 76 to you know a few thousand
um the natural question as well
how do we know that this model is
sufficiently representative of what's
happening in the device right and you
can do some very simple sanity checks
um you know one thing that we often see
with these devices is uh the
superconducting qubits are are every so
often plagued by interactions with these
defect 2 level systems that lead to a
loss of Deco a loss of coherence and
basically you know those qubits will
will come up with with you know pretty
large error rates so that that kind of
makes sense I'll I'll show you some more
some more sanity checks that we can do
to have to have some trust in this noise
model okay
but once we have this nice model
basically you can then begin to
introduce uh many different
randomizations where you're sampling
these these different polygates to
controllably amplify The Noise by the
desired
um noise amplification Factor that's of
Interest okay and then by by taking the
results and averaging over all the all
the results that you have from these
many different uh circuit runs you now
have access to an expectation value at
this Amplified noise level okay so this
is what this looks like in practice I
won't quite go into the details of the
circuit that was used for this but you
know just just for this purpose
um there's some circuit we're running
we're looking at some observable the
ideal answer is supposed to be one if we
run the circuit at the base noise level
that's g equals to one
um that's what we get and then we can
amplify it by a factor of 1.2 we run
2000 different circuits
um you know two thousand different
unique poly insertions uh at every gate
layer
um and and then that can gorgeous to to
what that expectation should be in the
simplification factor of 1.2 we can do
that for 1.6 as well and then if we try
and do linear extrapolation
um that's what we get with the light
blue there's also been work suggesting
exponential extrapolation can quite you
can work quite well from from Simon
Benjamin's group um that's something we
tried as well and that actually it seems
to seems to reduce the bias even further
and that's what we'll use for the vast
majority of the experiments that I I
talk about
okay cool
um all right so so we this is the method
we have the device we want to test it
out on some family of circuits right
um and and so what we're going to look
at is basically you know a poorly
trotterized time evolution of a 2d
transverse field isync model we're going
to look at a spin lattice that shares
the hardware topology
you know after initializing in the all
zero State we're going to start the
evolution and we're essentially trying
to to measure expectation values at
fixed depth and in this experiment we're
going to try and sweep this transverse
field
okay
so if you look at every individual
Trotter step this basically looks like
um RX Gates
um associated with this this transverse
field uh with this Theta angle parameter
on all the qubits and this is
interleaved with with ZZ interactions
that we want to implement on every Link
in the device because of the
connectivity all the red links can be
can be implemented in parallel so that
becomes one one layer so associated with
the red layer we learned the noise model
similarly all the Blue Links can be
implemented in one layer that becomes
another Associated noise model for that
after learning and similarly for degree
the reason we call this poorly is
because we're we're basically fixing
this the the throttle step for for the
ZZ gates to be to be a very large angle
pi over 2 and that's that's basically
because we want to implement this with
just one C naught operation
um and and something to note is is once
you fix that Theta J to be pi over 2
this circuit becomes Clifford for angles
0 and pi over two
okay
um
and yeah and just to give you a sense a
visual sense of the kind of circuits
we're running these are going up to 127
qubits with 60 entangling layers and and
if you look back at the experiment we
ran in 2017 with just four qubits in
depth two
um
this is this is one measure of of how
much progress we've made in our
understanding of the hardware how to
manipulate noise but also coherence
Timescape Fidelity scale all of these
things right
um okay so at at this scale we're Beyond
Brute Force
classical
methods and and the first step is is to
build some trust in the error mitigation
it's to build some trust in what we're
doing with the hardware right
um
so we're going to begin to look at these
these Clifford circuits uh to begin with
and
um and here
um
that's basically these these Theta uh
the the angle rotations for the for the
RX Gates you can go from zero to pi over
two
um and and at these two points these are
your Clifford these are your Clifford
parameters you have access to what the
exact result should be right
um if we look at this Global
magnetization
um that's basically the magnetized the Z
magnetization average over all 127 spins
um this is what we have in the absence
of any error mitigation the right answer
should have been one this represents the
bias from the noise which we're able to
mitigate and get a fairly accurate
result and then once again at pi over 2
that should have been zero and and
that's what we we also seem to get
um in in the experiment okay so at this
there's a very simple check of these two
points things things seem to work quite
well and then we can begin to to explore
these non-clifford regimes right we can
begin to sweep this uh sweep this
parameter space and and basically study
what's happening to the the unmitigated
signal and and how things you know
perhaps improve with with mitigation
how do we know if if this is correct or
not and that's that's why we had to rely
on on help from from my executive group
here
um and
and and and you know help get some help
with their expertise with with classical
approximations with tensor Network
methods right
um so this at these volumes are Beyond
Brute Force you have to make some
approximations
um and and you can think of you know
having access to some approximation
parameter that's referred to as the bond
Dimension and you're trying to
interpolate between these two extremes
where if you you know in your in your
approximation to the wave function if
your bond Dimension was one you're just
looking at very simple uh product States
and then
um you know if you wanted an exact
representation
um you have some exponential one
dimension right and you interpolate
between these two and that that could
depend on on on on your runtime
constraints or your memory constraints
on your classical supercomputer okay
um so we looked at um two different
um tensor Network methods that that that
uh that the group specialized in with
with matrix product States and a 2d
generalization uh of that uh that's
referred to as peps and then this is
this goes even Beyond to optimize
further uh ISO TNS to access what are
pretty large Bond dimensions for
um for these 2D tensor Network methods
and basically what we see is at these
small Theta angles
um there's pretty good agreement with
the experiment and uh and these
approximate methods
um but then as you go to larger Theta
angles there there are these deviations
and uh it wasn't quite clear to us at
this point in time which was correct
right
um and then what the team realized was
that we're only looking at these weight
one uh observables uh the magnetization
and the circuit depth is fairly small
so for for every site magnetization if
you actually asked what's the light cone
what are the number of qubits that are
actually playing a role in the accuracy
of that of that observable that turns
out to be a much smaller number
okay so then if you now do this if you
make use of the Litecoin now you have
access to what the Brute Force
um Evolution should have been for the
sitewise magnetization you could use
that to construct what the evolution is
for the global and then there you see
that the the ideal is is bang on with
the experiment so this was this was very
exciting to see that at the scale we're
able to actually do something reliable
with these machines okay maybe I can I
can pause here before I go ahead if
there are any questions
yeah please
please
the the the the the simulation of this
particular observable is
yes
right right exactly right so so at at
this for this observable particularly
because this is a very local wait one
observable you you have a the light
contains out to be fairly small at this
step right and part of the motivation
for also doing these tensor Network
methods is if the depth got larger then
the light cone will will go over the
entire device and and then you don't
have much to win from those kinds of
optimizations you might not have access
to the Brute Force anymore okay
yeah
I think we'll we'll get into that very
soon
um right okay so so one one criticism
could be well the pi over two point is
is interesting that's where you have
non-trivial entanglement Dynamics at
play well you could ask well you know
this is this is this is the right answer
this could have been the right answer
because the error mitigation worked very
well but it could have also been the
right answer because you landed up in a
completely mixed state right so how do
you how do you
how do you separate these two so for
that we wanted to look at you know
perhaps a stabilizer for the circuit
um where you have an observable that
that either takes you know a value of
one or minus one okay so the first thing
we did there was to look at some weight
and observable uh now we've increased
that Lite cone
um the ideal answer is supposed to be
one at the Spy over two point
um and and both these methods seem to
you know seem seem to fail it capturing
that but still
um the light cone goes up to about 37
qubits so we still have access to what
the exact Evolution should have been uh
and that agrees very well with the
experiment again
okay
um so so I I made this remark about
about the validity of our model and how
representative it is at this pi over two
point because this is a Clifford circuit
and you have access to a poly poly noise
Channel you can estimate what the what
the raw signal should have been in the
uh uh you know without any mitigation
basically and and if you look at what
that prediction is from the from the
noise channel that we have that actually
agrees quite well with with the
experiment right so this is this is
actually a very powerful indicator
almost of the success of an experiment
how much signal are we going to have and
how much signal can we post process with
to try and boost it up right and this
also gives some confidence into into the
kind of model assumptions we're making
we can then begin to go you know make
things even more complicated now going
up to a weight 17 observable
um the light cones even larger goes up
to 68 qubits you don't have access to
the exact from just Brute Force anymore
but but you know with some with some
additional tricks we were able to get
access to that as well and even here the
experiment uh agrees quite well with
with what the exact evolution is
right so basically what we're seeing
here is that with an existing noisy
quantum computer we're able to produce
accurate expectation values that are
Beyond Brute Force classical computation
and we're leading classical
approximations seem to struggle right
and this we're saying you know is
evidence for the utility of of quantum
Computing even before we have
um fault tolerance right
um and and once we've built trust in
this exactly verifiable regime
um the the icing on the cake uh you know
puns intended are are to go even Beyond
uh it's it's to look at even more
complex observables this is once again
another stabilizer
um also of weight 17 that we don't have
access to the Brute Force the exact
Evolution this is also a stabilizer at
the pi over two so we seem to get the
right answer there we have the right
answer at zero
um and then that gives us confidence
that perhaps this evolution is is more
accurate than than the MPS that we tried
here right
um
and then we also went out to a much
longer depth once again looking at these
these single side magnetizations and
here at this depth your your Litecoin
basically covers the entire 127 qubit
device and and and you don't have access
to uh uh what the what the exact
Evolution would have been right
um
one can one can ask the question of what
the runtimes were and it's it's sort of
meaningless to even compare because we
aren't comparing two things at the same
level of accuracy but you know I think
people might be interested uh you know
for the classical supercomputer we were
looking at about 30 hours for for a
single point
um there is a lot of overhead that we
have at the moment in terms of policy
generation circuit transformation that
also drives up uh the quantum wall clock
time
um but but if you looked at uh what was
the the actual time on the processor
where we were averaging over circuits
that's just about five minutes right and
I think
um uh there are immediately accessible
speed improvements to to to close the
gap between the quantum wall clock time
and the the device averaging time
um and uh you know similarly I think
they're also going to be they're also
going to be advances in In classical
algorithms and and you know more
interesting ways to use memory that that
might might might drive this number down
as well right
um someone could ask well are we
claiming that this is quantum Advantage
I I don't think we know yet uh you know
really when we started this experiment
out that's not what we were setting out
to do we just wanted to to demonstrate
the reliability of our our tool and
hardware at the scale uh the circuit is
not something you know we we chose that
has a formal hardness result
um but we're already seeing that even
you know already for these experiments
where we're seeing that these are
motivating extensions to to
state-of-the-art classical methods and
we expect this this back and forth and
and I think you know we're the place we
have this tool and and you know be
curious to get people's thoughts on on
on on on what kind of circuits should we
run and what kind of observables should
you measure and can one actually make a
more formal hardness statement about the
kind of things we want to run right and
as these these these classical
simulation methods evolve
um I think even our Hardware is going to
keep evolving these were the coherence
times that I'd shown on the R3 for the
device the gate fidelities uh this is
already the state of the art for a 127
qubit device but if you asked well what
is what are the best metrics that we
have internally at IBM which are also
you know the best metrics that exist for
superconducting Quantum Tech with trans
months
um
there are about an order of magnitude
improvements uh you know waiting uh
median coherence times of about 200 to
300 microseconds on the device the best
that we have are about four milliseconds
but transform qubits
um you know the median error rates were
close to one percent
um we have devices with with two qubit
error rates at the point one percent
level so I think there's a lot of reason
for optimism and we we anticipate that
we should be able to get to even larger
circuit volumes in the near future
um so with that thank you for your
attention
um I think uh I I won't harp on on some
of these points again because well we
said them a bunch of times but but we're
pretty excited I think we think we have
a tool for a really now testing out a
lot of near-term quantum algorithms that
have been proposed but just haven't been
tested at the scale uh I think that that
hopefully will motivate the exploration
of of more Quantum applications
um a key part of this this work I'll
emphasize again was to build trust in
the device and the mitigation method you
know we will be very interested you know
in in in carefully choosing uh other
circuits or if people have applications
you know we'd love to to hear your
thoughts and on what's what's good to
run on these
um I spoke about
um the zero noise extrapolation but we
also have more powerful error mitigation
techniques in the mix
um I I briefly alluded to this as
probabilistic error cancellation
um and and in the con in that context
also we're trying to get towards uh even
larger circuit volumes in the next one
here
um getting up to 100 by 100
um and and I think with this way of of
trying to do Quantum Computing we can
really build off uh incremental
improvements in coherence reduced
crosstalk in in Gate Fidelity and speed
quality scale all of these will will
very naturally tie into the kind of uh
circuit volumes we can we can now begin
to run on these devices and still get
accurate expectation values so with that
um thanks for your attention and happy
to take any questions
[Applause]
thanks for the talk very interesting um
in some of your previous work if I
remember correctly a lot of the driving
force
for the Improvement was due to dynamical
decoupling but you didn't mention
anything here so I was wondering when
you show the graphs for their sort of
mitigation
what what kind of schemes are you using
there is it is it is the major
Improvement coming for dynamical
decoupling still or is it does it show
that these kind of classical
post-processing based methods can really
push forward or raise it something
something more more closer to the
hardware that's going on yeah that's a
great question so I think that the
question was well is dynamically
decoupling what's crucial to see the
improvements here are we continuing to
do that the answer is yes it's very much
something we're doing uh just dynamical
decoupling alone won't get you to the
right answer it can reduce the effect of
defacing uh to some extent
um
with this kind of technique and this is
some this is an experiment we've also
done we we measure the noise models with
and without dynamical decoupling and as
long as you can accurately get some
sense of what that average model is even
if you did not have dynamical decoupling
you still would have been able to to
access these accurate results uh perhaps
you know because the errors would have
been larger you would have had more
sampling costs and so on
um but but yeah it's so so things like
dynamical decoupling we put in the
bucket of uh terminology that we refer
to as error suppression techniques
um uh so it's it's not quite post
processing there but it's something
you're actively doing in in your Quantum
circuit
thanks so much
do you know how their mitigation running
on the classical computer scales with
the number of qubits like let's say we
can do it for 127. do you think we can
do it for a thousand qubits or how does
it grow like how how big of a system do
you think we can do with error
mitigation yeah that's that's also a
great question and it kind of alludes it
connects to to what you what you Loosely
had on your on your talk as well as you
know maybe 1000 by 20 is easy so so with
zero noise extrapolation
um those kinds of estimations are
perhaps a little more heuristic but with
uh this other technique called
probabilistic error cancellation you can
actually quantify what the runtime
overhead is
right and you can quantify this as as
some base uh to the power of number of
qubits times depth
in the exponent okay and the base is
representative of of the average noise
in the device so assuming that you had a
thousand qubit device and 100 qubit
device at the same base noise it's
basically telling you that with the same
sampling cost you could have done the
same NB volume
so if you could do 100 by 100
with the same sampling cost you can do
thousand by 10.
yes it works
thanks for the great talk uh I was
wondering like if you have different
circuit connectivity like a higher
circuit connectivity does it only
influence the uh classical verification
or there there will be something
different from your error mitigation and
also like how the crosstalk uh and the
correlated error influence the error
mitigation strategy right right so so if
you had if you had higher um sorry so
the the question was was the first
question was how does the how would
higher connectivity affect the air
mitigation right
um right so so if you still had say you
went from the heavy hex to the square
topology that's still next that's the
nearest neighbor connectivity and and
you would still the number of model
terms you would need to you would need
to learn uh would still be linear in in
system size okay so that that wouldn't
change much
um
it's not something I I I
I dove too deep into but the the form of
that that the form of that noise model
as a composition of simple Maps
um even though we have these these local
these locality assumptions on the noise
you still are capturing crosstalk
um when you have uh
yeah so I I didn't go in too much depth
here but but basically these represent
nine different model uh model parameters
for every link on the device so if you
had crosstalk between between a pair of
connected qubits that gets captured here
you can also ask well
um uh well if you were driving qubit 65
and then you had you had some uh some
error because of that pulse on 87 does
that get captured that also gets
captured if it's particularly off of the
form with with a with the weight one
generator
um that that also would get captured so
so even
with the Simplicity of the the model you
are sensitive to the crosstalk and
correlated errors and so on right um if
if we if if we instead of you know
completely populating the device with
all the two qubit gates if we instead
only had you know half of them we are
getting a different set of of model
parameters so so that does get that does
get captured in in the noise model
all right
the observable that you chose here was a
local observable so I was wondering if
the error mitigation strategy that you
have would work for let's say a two
point correlator for two qubits that are
well separated in your system yeah
that's that's a that's a that's a great
question
um so the experimentalist response to
that would be it depends on how much
signal you have
and and by by signal I refer to these
Green Dots right if these green dots are
very close to zero and and the ideal
answer was one that's very hard to to
kind of extrapolate with zero noise
extrapolation I can I can show you other
examples where we've been able to still
recover it with other techniques
um but but basically it it's a function
of many different things there isn't a
very simple simple answer it depends on
how quickly errors are propagating what
the light cone for that circuit is uh
and I think like with things like this
uh these uh uh these these these
Clifford noisy simulations you can begin
to you know you can begin to predict
quite reliably how much signal the
experiment will produce once you have
access to a fairly representative noise
model so so that would typically be the
way to go if you know to to to to to to
try and guess what the success of you
know assimilation with those kinds of
observables might be right but but also
you know we were going Beyond just with
weight once just to emphasize we were
looking at you know these weight 10
weight 17 observables which were also
you know not as local but but still the
experiment seems to do quite well
let's take one more question
I'll bring the mic over
maybe you can uh it's like an extension
of the previous question okay comment on
like what kind of observable you are not
expecting this thing to be working this
method to work but I somehow feel like
you are running your machine Quantum
machine like uh analog content simulator
and there are like say you have a
interactive super fruit the energy of
the ground state is well estimatable
while the face in every run like if you
prepare a super fluid yes we know it's
not like it will be different every run
because spontaneous symmetry breaking
and is there something similar in your
system here are you expecting yeah yeah
um so so this was what I was alluding to
in my response to the previous previous
question so so maybe just to summarize
the question again that the question is
uh
are there other observables where we
think we can't reconstruct what the
ideal result should be right
um so this is another experiment
this was this was not the experiment
with zero noise extrapolation so we're
not amplifying the noise
probabilistically uh but instead we're
trying to to cancel the noise
probabilistically so that gain factor
that I had was positive we're making
negative and that comes with some
additional sampling cost this the
technique is called probabilistic error
cancellation and this was a very
simplistic circuit this was just a 50 50
qubit circuit with a depth of two so
just two c naught Gates but what we're
doing here is on the x-axis we're
increasing systematically the weight of
a z observable on that circuit so what
you have right at the end is a weight 49
observable
okay
um so the ideal answer is supposed to be
one and that's what your raw signal is
can I extrapolate from that I don't
think so
okay so if I tried zero noise
extrapolation on that that that's going
to require a massive sampling cost but
instead if I do cancellation I can I can
actually extract
you know a number pretty close to one
there is some bias and you know but but
as an experimentalist to take that
signal and get there that kind of blows
my mind so so so so this is what I mean
by you know more powerful techniques
that that we haven't
uh that I didn't discuss in this talk
but this is also in the works right
right
um but yeah I mean this this example
looks at basically very high weight uh
Observer observables and and still
conveys like how you can recover some of
this
thank you